allez allez
isabelle morini-bosc que je m'arrêtais
tout de suite sur vous avez passé une
belle soirée jeudi soir avec nous oui
mais un jour j'aimerais bien prendre
mathieu au badminton est ce que vous
voulez mais bon tout le monde ne peut
pas passer dessus non plus novell minton
je veux bien le pari contre isabelle
puisque car vous mais elle joue très
bien c'est une championne de badji a
éclaté au bras de fer
je vous le dis alors je savais pas
isabelle mais vous êtes une toute autre
personne en soirée en fait c'est là
c'est plus tata isa mais regardez c'est
tata la caillera regardez moi
j'ai tellement donné que j'ai mal à mon
coeur maintenant
et et nous le dit on a on a notre truc
notre autre image dont je me lasse pas
d'isabelle c'est l'attraction de
l'ascenseur alors pour ceux qui n'ont
pas du vendredi je voulais vraiment vous
remettrez la tête de toute l'équipe mais
focaliser juste je vous jure sur la tête
isabelle morizet nous regarder quels et
vous allez comprendre les problèmes
qu'elle peut avoir voilà or émission
regarde on va faire une attraction à
l'ascenseur
moi bertrand avait pu les rassurer
non
bertrand et heureusement d'ailleurs
on dirait mais pas tant que ça j'ai
adoré moi on va vous dire m vous ferez
ça ici on va le faire ici
oh